there's a new reality television program
and it's called the blue I should
probably write it in blue but it's
called the blue for head room blue for
head head room and what they do in this
reality television program and and
you'll have to bear with me because this
show probably wouldn't be that
interesting to watch but it's
interesting to predict what happens what
they do is they take a room we'll call
it the blue for head room and they let's
see that's that's kind of a top view of
the room and let's say there's a door
here none of this is relevant to the
actual problem this is the door right oh
right there
and what they do is they get 100 perfect
logicians to sit in this room in a
circle so they're all you know sitting
in a circle in this room now before the
game even starts before they even enter
the room the first time the logicians
are told two things they're told one
that at least one of you at least one of
you has your forehead painted blue has
your forehead painted blue at least one
of you has referred and maybe you know
that they all get their foreheads
painted so that you know obviously if
you're the only guy who has your
forehead painted and you know but you
don't know what color it is so all of
them have different color foreheads
right or we don't know but all they're
told is look you know obviously I've
painted your forehead and at least one
of the people in the room that you will
enter will have their forehead painted
blue and then they're also told that as
soon as soon as you deduce that your
forehead blue that your forehead is blue
that you're blue you need to leave the
room you need to leave the room and
what's going to happen is and it's it's
very important that I set this up
properly
they're all outside of the room no one's
inside the room and let's say they're
blindfolded and while they're
blindfolded they essentially you know
have the thing you know painted onto
their forehead so they can't see the
paintbrush or anything so really really
don't know what's on their forehead and
they just have to use and and then after
that they're essentially allowed they
all enter the room right and they all
sit in a circle like this so that they
can all look each other then the
foreheads and then the and then the and
let's say when they enter the lights are
off right so the lights are off and then
what the the the protocol is is that the
lights will be turned on and then they
can all look around at each other
there's no reflective surfaces they
can't look at it you know look into each
other's eyes and try to see the
reflection no tricks like that there are
no mirrors in this room nothing like
that all they can do is look at each
other so let's you know just as an
example let's say that this is me right
here as soon as the lights get turned on
the first time I'll be able to look at
all the other people in the room and I
could see really it'll be pretty obvious
to me if anyone has a blue forehead
right eye maybe that guy has one that
guy I don't know right and I could see
them I can't see my own forehead and
what happens is it then they will turn
off the lights and the way they're going
to do it is you have to leave the room
after you have realized that you have a
blue forehead so for example let's say I
enter into the room and you know because
I'm a perfect logician I see things that
make allow me to perfectly to do deduce
that I have a blue forehead then what
they're going to do is they're going to
turn off the lights again and then if I
know that I have a blue forehead while
the lights are turned off I would leave
the room and then when they turn the
lights back on I'd be gone so there
would be no Sal here so you know let's
say they're 100 before then there would
be 99 guys sitting in the room right as
soon as I I as soon as I realize I have
a blue forehead when the lights get
turned off I leave right and just
remember these are perfect logicians so
everyone in the minute and and and not
only are they all perfect logicians but
they all know that everyone else is a
perfect logician so everyone is also
told
and this is true everyone everyone is
perfect logician which means they have
infallible powers of logic perfect
logician logician so my question to you
so you know just remember I have you
know each of these perfect logicians we
set them up outside of the room paint
their foreheads they're blindfolded they
have no clue then we have all of them
walk into a dark room sit in a circle
like this and then what we tell them is
as soon as you realize that you have a
blue forehead as soon as you have a blue
forehead you have to leave the room now
my question to you is let's say that
we've actually painted everybody's
forehead blue what happens so remember
we've this is what we've told each of
the people right as soon as you realize
your forehead is blue you leave the room
and now I've just asked you what happens
and you know the producers like to
really play with these logicians they've
actually painted everybody's forehead
blue so you know you know when when
everyone goes to the room the first time
what's going to happen you know let's
say this is let's say I'm one of the
logicians this is me right right here as
soon as I open my eyes I'm going to see
99 other fellow logicians with blue
foreheads so that's that's just kind of
and then you know maybe I can somehow to
do something about my own not you know I
don't think you can and then the lights
will go off and then you know if I
haven't deduced anything about my own
blueness of my forehead then they'll
turn the lights back on and then maybe
some other guy will have left I don't
know or or maybe not and then I'll see
the same 99 guys again and that'll just
keep occurring until something happens
and my question to you is what happens
when and why and that's the well I'm
thinking whether I should give you a
hint right now well let me tell you this
way that's the problem you should be
able to solve it and just you know where
this came from this side if I remember
correctly I think this Kate was on a
computer science exam I had at MIT so
it's a
you know just so you know this isn't
just for fun this is this could actually
you know this well I I don't want to I
don't want to go into the into the into
all the applications that this type of
problem can apply to because that by
itself would be a bit of a hint but let
me so if you don't want a hint turn off
the video now or pause it if you do want
a hint well I'm about to give it to you
so my hint is my hint and remember turn
this off if you don't want a hint but
the hint is what happens what happens
when there are less than 100 people so
you know I gave the the situation where
we have a hundred logicians but this
problem is actually a lot easier if you
try it with a smaller number anyway I'll
see you in the solution video